Domestic violence has been in the news a lot
lately - but how common is it?
And is there a way to identify perpetrators
before they strike?
Hey guys, Tara here for Dnews - and if you’ve
been paying attention to the news lately,
then you’ve probably heard about this whole
Ray Rice fiasco, which is sadly, just one
of the domestic violence cases currently surrounding
the NFL.
What you may not be aware of, though - are
the actual statistics regarding these kinds
of issues.
According to a new study from the University
of Michigan, 1 in 5 men in the United States
reports having committed violence against
their spouse or significant other.
Violence against women, specifically, accounts
for almost 320,000 outpatient health visits
and 1,200 deaths every year.
That’s nearly $8.3 billion spent on medical
and mental health services alone.
But the scariest statistic of all?
In this country, domestic violence is more
common than diabetes.
This particular study included a nationally-representative
survey sample of 530 men with an average age
of 42.
“Intimate partner violence” was defined
as pushing, grabbing, shoving, throwing something,
slapping or hitting, kicking, biting, beating
up, choking, burning or scalding, or threatening
a partner with a knife or gun.
So, pretty severe stuff.
What’s especially eye-opening about these
findings, is that male aggression towards
a partner, is associated with certain warning
signs - signs that often pop up during routine
health care visits.
Irritable bowel syndrome, insomnia, substance
abuse, and a history of either experiencing
or witnessing violence as a child - are all
things that male aggressors experience more
frequently than others.
According to lead author Vijay Singh, the
issue of domestic violence is one that “cuts
across all communities, regardless of race,
income, or any other demographics."
Most of the efforts up until now, have focused
on screening and improving outcomes for female
victims.
But very little work has been done to actually
identify male perpetrators.
Which is why this study is so important.
It shows just how much of an opportunity we’re
missing, to identify aggressive behavior in
the primary care setting, and potentially
intervene.
Now - switching gears for a second, I wanna
remind everyone out there watching this, that
I host another another show here on Discovery
called TestTube.
It’s a lot like Dnews - but more focused
on current events; however there is still
some science stuff in there, like this episode
I hosted about why it’s so difficult to
actually eradicate disease.
You can find that, along with many other episodes,
over at youtube.com/testtubenetwork.
And in the meantime, if you guys have any
questions, comments, anything you wanna say
about this episode - let us know in the comments
below.
Otherwise, thanks for watching!